December 2002 NASA's Landsat 7 satellite
captures an image of the Antarctic ice
shelf something about these stains
doesn't add up
scientists expand their investigation to
include the possibility the marks could
be linked to the local wildlife the most
likely explanation for what we're
looking at here is some sort of
ecological footprint and there are many
species in Antarctica but Antarctica is
home to one of the most unusual Birds on
the planet the emperor penguin emperor
penguins are amazing birds because they
can live in this frigid wasteland and
they find their food by swimming around
in the sea and then they come back up
and form these giant colonies where they
had their babies
they grouped together you know to keep
themselves warm
biologists studying the distribution of
the stains discover they line up
perfectly with several vast colonies of
emperor penguins made up of tens of
thousands of individual birds there's
more recent satellite imagery that we
have access to this high-resolution
where we can even count the number of
penguins that we're looking at
the higher resolution images make it
clear how the Penguins are causing the
brown stains it really is amazing to me
that what we're looking at here is
penguin poo from space it turns out that
hundreds of thousands of penguins have
left an indelible mark on the icy
landscape in their poo today scientists
can use satellite images of the massive
skid marks on Antarctica as a way of
actually monitoring the resident penguin
population one of the things I find
particularly remarkable is that if a
group of birds can create enough guano
to be seen from space then that means
that it's doing pretty well
[Music]
you